hey Jason your question for Chris and me
hey dude a good man how can I help me
and my wife just now started getting
into I think I got her convinced into
start your program and third issue is
our but I don't have a steady income
I get paid percent of the load mm-hmm so
my paychecks burying work from $500
$50,000 a week per paycheck is steady
she's not she doesn't see how that's
gonna quit okay all right Chris you
won't jump on that one yeah so what's
her what's her income you said it was
steady yeah you gettin paid by the hour
she brings home about eight hundred
dollars every two weeks okay all right
well with regular income what we like to
do is make sure you list your expenses
out from a need to a want so you want to
do take care of your you know things
that have to happen like your shelter
your clothing your food and these are
your necessities you know not like you
know not your extreme food not your
extreme clothing this is just your basic
necessities take care of those first
with the income that comes in okay and
then also your transportation and that
would include utilities as well so those
things that you need to take care of
take care of those first and then you're
gonna start getting into recreation and
some of the other things and that first
check that comes in let's say it is 500
bucks you're gonna put that towards what
needs to be paid first the next one
comes in for 700 then you go you're not
gonna make sure you can't pay through
you can't pay everything off right away
but at least you're gonna be taking care
of the needs first now I'm assuming you
guys are combined finances right yes
okay so you know you want to make sure
that you you know obviously we've got
heard income that is more consistent you
should be able to do that fine but you
just want to list them from needs to
once so if you'll do a regular budget
Jason with the $500 that is your minimum
you know you're gonna get 500 right and
and and her 800 - every two weeks your
500s per week right
yes okay so that's two thousand a month
she's making a sixteen hundred a month
so you've got 3,600 a month that you'd
do a regular budget with does that make
sense
yes yeah
we when we did that I went over it with
local on the paycheck at a at 500 off
high side and we're about $400 sides
yeah
break it even pay the bill yeah and the
likelihood of you having for $500 weeks
is almost zero you never have yeah I
mean it just doesn't happen so we know
we got more than that but let's lay out
the budget like Chris said from most
important thing to least important thing
and and and do the most you can do with
a 3600 that's set there and then make a
list of the things that didn't make that
cut that first 400 that you talked about
right where you're shy if you do the
five hundred dollar a week thing and
then you know I from there you make a
list of everything from most important
to least important and then you take
whatever money you have come in and go
down that second list but your first
budget you take care of your necessities
and as much as you can in the 3600 and
go from there and then make a list of
most important to least important from
that point forward and if everything
everything has a name in advance we just
don't know how far down the list you're
gonna get because we don't know how much
money you're gonna make
all right does that make sense to you
yes it does I appreciate it now do you
have any of our books I did buy one is
your one for the kids to eat my sister
okay you don't you don't have on it you
don't have a book for you guys all right
let me give you let me give you a total
money makeover book because in the back
of that book are the budget forms and
one of those forms explains this it's
called the irregular income planning
sheet and it'll help you so hold on I'll
have Kelly pick up will give you a copy
of that and also you can jump on every
dollar calm and do your budget for free
there as well so hey thanks for calling
in dude we appreciate you